the National Football League's NFC South
Conference got that much more difficult
when Tom Brady decided to make his
residence there professionally and the
head coach of the Atlanta Falcons
joining us right now on the Rich Eisen
show great to say hello to the gentleman
referred to in the league and certainly
in his in his locker room as DQ Dan
Quinn here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you Dan
hey rich I'm doing good man it's always
good to be on with you and we're getting
started so yeah man everything's good
here glad to hear that everything good
with your family everything all good
yeah everything's good with us and with
the team and so in this new space
there's been a lot of good connections
you know a lot of one-on-one meetings
bought to customize you know learning
and programs for the fellows so there's
definitely you know some ways to gain
advantages even in a unusual time
excellent so I want to put a pin in that
for the moment and return to it I want
to get into the history of you in the
NFL is it true that if it wasn't for a
phone call from Steve Mariucci to your
house and asked for you to put your wife
on the phone
to talk to her to make sure that
everyone was on board for him to hire
you that potentially you you weren't
talking to me as a head coach the
Atlanta Falcons right now would that be
a potentially accurate statement Dan oh
definitely not accurate but it is 100%
accurate test oops did that and I would
say like they don't want to like the
coolest and classic movies of all time
so what what did he do again Dan because
again I don't want to say that he takes
full recessed
but it's it's close to full it's close
to fitting 100% should be and my part of
the cool thing so rich I interviewed
with mooch and the staff there and I
remember you know getting on the plane
and you know flying back to New York as
well as living at the time and I'll call
you tomorrow
and so you know like most things
tomorrow comes and you know goes through
the day and at the time I was working at
Hofstra and I was the strength coach as
well so I can member somebody like you
know Stan
phone and my desk a man if this dude
calls me you come down to the weight
room and grab and so you know four
o'clock comes five o'clock at you know
the home at 7:00 and so that night you
know I'm thinking didn't happen you know
and so about you know like 10 o'clock at
night the phone rang and it was mooch
and he said you know hey I want to you
know offer you the job that's oh by the
way is your wife there I looked over to
Stacy and I said you know kind of
covered up the phone like you could do
before cellphone stuff I said he wants
to talk to you and her eyes got big you
know as you could imagine like what and
I was like I don't you know give the
shoulder shrug and I just hand him the
phone and then he says hey you know
we're offering this job today and I'm
just gonna welcome you to it - and so
like from that moment on like there's a
lot of people in the NFL but if you want
to talk about like the number of people
Stacy would fight somebody for mooch is
part of that group because he made our
transition from college into the NFL as
smooth as it could be so it was the
ideal spot to learn and watch him and so
for two years every leading everyone
just like I have notebooks of Steve
Mariucci meetings and conversations just
because it would be a ideal person of
what it could look like for me as a you
know as a young coach first coming into
the NFL and so it was honestly like the
best runway you could have which for an
NFL coaching career like - to learn from
him and so yeah he definitely had a big
influence and I would say in our house
if there's one coach I would go by them
first some days I am some days not but
definitely second from a coaching side
so if we're wondering where Wayne
Chrebet got his strength from at Hofstra
is that you Dan is that what you're
saying good connection Vario Dave fury
played out at the Niners for a while
sure land shelters who the safety and so
yeah don't think that I didn't call all
of them damaged in moochick Hall you
know like anything trying like hell to
find one sliver of a connection to them
and it was at one time that you got the
opportunity to do an interview and I
thought it went well but then of course
the next day I was like nah man I missed
it and so he called that night about 10
o'clock it was a definitely a phone call
for me that was my draft a story you
know like my you know kind of my rookie
draft call but it was you know for me
didn't play in the NFL that was just as
good to me
I love mooch - so does my wife so does
everybody that works with him at NFL
Network or has ever come across them I
mean I guess everyone not named Terrell
Owens but other than that you know I
mean that's just that's for another show
but he's just a great person man and I'm
glad to hear that and and and it's
amazing again you know you've been
around him and obviously Pete Carroll so
you've been around guys or a pretty high
energy high high high energy for sure
and I imagine that's kind of needed
right now too right I mean even though
you're not physically there with these
guys you kind of need to bring that to
the better have that and there's
definitely ways that has to come across
you know especially when Richard meeting
you know these 25 rookies for the first
time right and so try to build a
relationship with them and get connected
with them it's like okay to get to know
you what do I really need to do like I
know your stats I can look you up on
Google to Scouts event at the school but
having those one-on-one conversations
that's the thing to me that makes the
difference and so fortunately we've had
those one-on-ones whatever chance to
visit away from football off the field
you know what are the things that wake
up and your family background and then
you can kind of start building that on
the football side but it was um that's
one thing I would say moving forward
every year I didn't always do that to
have a one-on-one you know FaceTime call
with every player prior to looking in
camp but I will from now on because
having that uninterrupted time entering
into a team and a culture and what's
expected of you seems you know something
that I'm definitely going to use for
moving forward so what are you being
told right now coach Dan Quinn of the
Falcons where
about about when you think there could
be a protocol for a mini camp or a
training camp or anything of that nature
where does that currently stand for you
yeah and that's the hardest part for
everybody you know because they wanted
to to look down the road understand how
to use their like a kick-ass week and so
I try to give the guys guidelines just
as soon as they're concrete once they
become more concrete than I can you know
some to them I don't want to throw out
good stuff to them and then you know say
hey this ask to change I kind of went
the other approach risk to say I know
right now outside there's a lot of
things that what we can't do what we
don't know but here's what I do know and
what we can do and so that's men there
worked out some of the guys are working
out together you know here in Georgia
where they're allowed to do it they're
not allowed to do it at the facility
some people are in their homes all over
like you know in California a guy like
Alex Mack who's there doing training on
his own and then they you know have you
know connections online with the guy so
it's really a customized offseason
program at the moment we've had meetings
where they're one-on-one then the next
space is one on some and then I'm sure
you've been on some calls to work like
we do a zoom meeting words you know 50
people or you know they those have to be
quick man it's kind of like reporting
the movies and and sharing it it's hard
to have especially forgot like if I
appreciate this who like humor you know
when the microphones are off and you
don't have body language some of the
humor part that you like to have fun at
the team meetings you don't get to
incorporate that as much as you do in
your one-on-one so lot to learn but as
far as down the line I've just tried to
stay a man with food this is the intent
for the week like a team meeting on a
Monday and let's do a kick-ass week you
know for the next four days and then
I'll reconnect with you every weekend
and we'll set it again for Monday so I
guess you even have the into Will
Ferrell that uh that Coach Carroll has
for I mean Yuma I mean look we can find
some comedians who love the Atlanta
Falcons that diversity yeah we do and
Argentina so yeah it is on with us okay
like without you know the audio
laughter right and they said like Dan
that is the thing you know where it's
like you don't hear everybody and see
them and so like for those of us who
love like the interaction with the team
and the players that part you don't get
to do so you just try to find other ways
to do it like staff meetings we get to
see everybody that's better than a you
know a conference call so you just try
to find little wins Matt and where
you're gonna be
Will Ferrell's it's funny as you can and
I've been in meetings before where he's
come in you know during my time in
Seattle and I can live like one time
literally I'm like tears you know Adam I
feels like like it was like ad-lib so
quickly to do this super talented man it
was uh it was in New Orleans in like
2010 and I can remember like its gesture
yeah yeah Kenny Thompson though he's
been a more Saturday Night Live sketches
than anybody else so I mean you can go
toe to toe you got you you've got will
be here everybody ask to battle so Pete
and I will scene in team just bring it I
like it
Dan Quinn few minutes left with the
Atlanta Falcons head coach here on the
Rich Eisen show and another tough aspect
of not being will have players there is
who you know what what what do you have
in a player like Todd Gurley and your
offensive coordinator Dirk cutter today
on a zoom conference call with reporters
said that no one seems to know what is
his health status in his workload etc so
on and so forth what what can you what
what can you tell us about Todd Girly's
readiness and his health status coach I
think yeah we you know we have a number
of new players you know that we've added
and so for all those guys you know we're
trying to we'll get to know them better
you know when they get here in their
round so on the offensive side it's Todd
and Havenhurst you know like we haven't
got to you know be around Hayden you
know what's the practice like and same
thing with Todd you know what's going to
be the the best battle rhythm for him
during the week on a Wednesday Thursday
Friday to get him at his best he's going
to be such a big part of our offense
I'm sure that's what it's referring to
you know to how much is the right amount
for him and that's our
job as coaches the once the guys get
here is to help them understand and
learn that the best we can and that's a
good communication that along between
you know Todd myself the same thing you
know was we do that with Julio too
and so what's the right amount of you
know for him during the week know and
that's you know on game day we want to
get the best version of him and so
that's we will undo the table that's
what you want to do with Hayden you know
Dante Fowler you know anybody that moves
the program getting to know the guys and
understanding the best and had a feature
on desk so Todd gets here like you've
already had those you know conversations
obviously but we'll make sure that we
get the best you know for to him and
where's the practice we look like to
make sure on Sundays we get the pitcher
and all the best stuff that he does so
don't forget that but I'm assuming when
you and Thomas dimitrov and and the rest
of the Falcons brass gets together to
make a decision on signing somebody like
Todd Gurley was just a conversation of
like we've known what he can do we see
what he can do you know obviously he is
he's a guy who's here but there's a risk
I mean it was kind of sight unseen in
that regard
right and so I think it's in some spaces
it's probably even more difficult for a
player that you know finished on IR or
had to do you know a surgery or a
procedure in the offseason so that
definitely helped were you know when you
Todd was able to finish the season there
so that that's a big piece of it you
know knowing that he came through the
season you know healthy and didn't have
a body you know surgery in the offseason
so won't that you know happened then we
knew okay we got a chance to see worried
that and how we could feature in the
often but I think you know what is the
right amount that'll have to be you know
in training camp and in the season so we
find our battle rhythm with him of what
his best looks like for the whole year
and so we're looking forward to do all
right well I'm you're the first coach in
the NFC South I've spoken to on the show
since Tom Brady has signed other than
airings will you be the first to say
bring it will you be the first to say it
give me that exclusive as an NFC South
coach telling Tom Brady let's don't
yeah I think yes see I think that you
wanted it but what I think you're gonna
see this year is like yeah there's gonna
be some kickass quarterback play and
that includes coming from number two
right here from our team so yes you know
for the team that are playing in this
conference you know certainly those guys
you know stand amongst a good group even
you know even taller so we've got some
good quarterbacks you know even in our
first part of our schedule rich I think
in our first four games like Russell
Wilson dak Prescott and Rogers in the
first you know three of the first four
games and so at the end of our you know
in the NFC you know like I said with our
division with the second half of the
season we breathe and Brady alone and
mahomes it's definitely a you know good
quarterback driven schedule and one that
we'll know right exactly where we're at
man so we're ready - we're ready to get
Rocking fantastic look forward to that
as you know number two Matt Ryan many
people refer to him as Maddie ice I've
been trying to get him four years to
accept the nickname of the natural what
will it take for you to just drop that
into a zoom refer to him as the natural
yes coach I'm using this last moment to
real estate with Dan Quinn take for you
to refer him once as the match we'll
just in passing come on I mean just one
one time just really casual all the
natural you have the floor whatever
whatever you gonna do I think
he's way too gritty and tough you see
the external nice moves like Matt Ryan
is a straight wolf in sheep's clothing
like he is a rare competitor he's tough
as hell so yeah that's one thing I
wouldn't you know go with him like dude
puts it in four so it would almost be an
insult to him that it comes to a
naturally like he is 100% driven grinder
tough-ass so that's why it wouldn't come
natural for me to call him back you
gotta move on you gotta move on so he
told me the last time I was about to say
come naturally but you know what do you
mind yeah sometimes you just gotta let
it go all right Chris you gotta move on
you gotta move on all right I'm loud and
clear
thanks for the [ __ ] time coach you take
care of yourself that's Dan Quinn you're
gonna start faulting a guy for trying
I'm gonna keep trying I implore you to
please stop nope rich you gotta move on
you gotta move on I'm undaunted